well
well listen everybody i want to give you
a warm welcome my name is jack reynolds
the
henry j heinz director of the yale
university art gallery before i go into
more of my formal welcome my dear friend
emeritus dean richard benson insisted i
hand out exam blue books to all of you
so uh
chip no okay
he teases me incessantly so i have to
give him a little shot here now that
he's back for a visit but listen
everybody i have to tell you it's an
enormous pleasure to be here today with
so many of my colleagues who work in the
museum but most of all to be with so
many of you who supported this places
great teachers great artists great
patrons supporters members some cases my
neighbors here in this wonderful city of
new haven uh we're just enormously
pleased at this point in time after uh
14 years of hard work together on
richard levin's whole master plan for
the yale arts area to be able to share
the
three building yale university art
collection now fully restored fully
reinstalled with eight magnificent
collections of huge education center
eight object classrooms in a sense now
we're really open for business and yet
everything we've done is built on the
history of those who've come before us
this is an extraordinary institution
i was the first university to have a art
museum on its campus the first to have
an art school
and i'm going to try and probably a
little over an hour to tell you the
story as quickly as i can with as many
images as i can and some of you are
going to be able to probably correct the
mistakes i meant and along the way i'm
going to talk about what we've done in
this renovation and expansion and
reinstallation
so let's bring the lights down
the story starts with an artist
and that artist was uh john trumbull you
see him here a little over the age of
40.
he grew up in connecticut he was the son
of the colonial governor of connecticut
the only colonial governor to break with
the british and side with american
revolution
and his son wanted to be an artist from
early age but his father made him go to
another place instead to harvard trained
to be a lawyer he argued with his dad
said he didn't want to do it he'd stop
at harvard and check it out if his
father took him to the studio of john
singleton copley because he'd heard
there was at least one person in america
who could and was becoming an artist
and he then became later in life having
graduated from harvard at 18 and aided
the camp to george washington his
brother also worked for washington
and he revered washington as many people
in our soon-to-be country did
he worked with him first in boston
helping site where the british were at
the bunker hill then went to fort
ticonderoga which board the hell out of
him and then went back and forth to
europe helping to provision our country
he throughout his life when he came back
uh pursued his interest in art he became
a wonderful painter he worked with
people like benjamin west copley gilbert
stewart others mentored him and after
the war he came back to america with the
purpose of really documenting uh
portraits there were no photographs
there for all you no cameras there for
all your photographers in the audience
he had to go around on his horse or in
person and meet with every single person
he wanted to do a likeness of and he
wanted to make sure people knew what
these people
that time looked like for the future
here you see amongst the five john adams
here you see amongst five great women
martha washington
and what people told him particularly
the older artists working in england but
west and copley is you have to go back
to america and paint the great battle
scenes the history paintings of our time
when we broke free of the british but
thomas thomas jefferson grabbed him
aside when he came to visit in paris and
said yes you should do that but most
importantly you should make two other
paintings the signing the declaration of
independence
you should do the battle scenes but also
just as importantly you should do
washington resigning his commission
because it's these first two things the
declaration of independence the idea of
america and the fact that he could have
been king and didn't choose to be is
what people really need to know not
about just the fighting
so trumbull uh there was no place to put
his art at that point in time his cousin
benjamin benjamin silliman was one of
the great professors at yale who
actually got eel started in both the
arts and sciences
yale went out and raised 7 500
1931 32 the first public money it ever
got from the state
and trumbull himself designed the
trumbull gallery oversaw its
construction brought it in a thousand
dollars under cost that's never been
done since
and
he was given a thousand dollar a year
annuity he moved his collection into a
fireproof building he turned down the
request from wadsworth i mean from
hartford that he shares collection there
they did for a while and in 1842 10
years later the wadsworth opened as the
first city museum in america but here at
yale there's the
trumbull gallery he installs his art in
1832 moves into his paintings and he
teaches for almost 10 years before he
dies he and his wife are then entombed
under the gallery and the collection
remains uh there to this
until the next thing that happened and
in 1866 that building on the old campus
was turned into the treasury
in the meantime the next thing happens
during another cataclysmic war the
american civil war breaks out
and in 1864 in the midst of it the
streets of new haven prosperous citizens
who'd gone to paris
came back and said what uh america needs
is a wonderful art school like we've
seen in paris and it should be a place
not only where yale students can come
but also
people from the city of new haven ought
to be able to study there and we'd like
to build that for the college and would
it like to have it
people here said yes this is a good idea
it's a
front door could open right onto chapel
street as it does today and it's side
door open under the west campus which it
still does today this was the design of
peter bonnet white one of the great
architects of the time of ruskinian
gothic
building you can see even value
engineering for those of you in our
architectural community and there are
many of you here today including our own
great architects from india a few
details didn't make it on even in the
budget issues of the civil war
but in
1866 behind the yale fence that used to
go all the way around the campus street
hall opened
and
its second floor galleries had the art
moved over from the trumbull gallery
and this is somewhat uh what it looked
like
if you go into street hall now those of
you been there already the american
painting sculpture collection is on view
there
much of it was on view back then but
also the first great italian renaissance
collection in america came to yale in
the in the
1870s and along with great prints and
those two were
on display up upstairs so there's a
whole history and you've seen much of
this architectural detail has been
reclaimed and beautifully restored one
of the major differences is you no
longer have gas lighting
and so again here are some of the great
italian pictures that came in at the
time the galleries upstairs the richard
feigen galleries have the greatest
collection of cn's early italian
painting outside of siena rivaled only
by that at the metropolitan
and the metropolitan along with yale
also received the great share of the
griggs collection
and for the first time with larry cantor
now as our chief curator lured away from
the met we have a real true expert in
that field but back to street hall
notice if you will as you look around
these studios for the first time you're
not simply seeing men of yale but you're
seeing women you've seen people of color
all working together whether it's
studying architecture whether it's doing
sculpture life drawing painting
and you also see people in their studios
art was made in the same building
where the students were and those were
the two floors below interestingly
enough field didn't have a formal art
history department until 1940. the
traditions at yale have always been much
more
make art study next to the works and
also over time integrate the love of art
into an undergraduate liberal arts
education it's an amazing tradition
well like all times uh things you were
starting to run out of space and run out
of space they did again they needed more
space there was an addition to street
hall in 1911 that was successful
it's melded into the building in a
wonderful way and a part of a part of
that you'll you'll see in the in in the
way it then connects later to the sward
owl building which some people know as
the old el art gallery and that was
coupled to street hall bridged over high
street and this is a color postcard we
found not long ago from 1928 you notice
the cars are just the kind that richard
benson also likes to drive
right chip i'm going to get you tonight
and uh
so the thing you need to know about this
word out building is it only it only
went over it went over high street here
there's the sword out tower it went this
far and then it stopped and what stopped
it
19 after 1928 with an open they were
thinking going further and then the
great depression hit so there's either
been a war of some or some economic
upheaval is often the latest stop to
expansion plants plans if had not done
that it would have gone all the way to
york street and there would have been a
main entrance here in the sculpture
garden going into what's now johnson
edwards college would have been a much
larger affair than it is now so none of
this got built it got built from here
over
and this is how it looked in 1928
and you see the great uh sculpture hall
which has now been returned to what it
was in 28 which is a place from for
classical sculpture you even see we were
able to find and refurbish the original
lamps and lighting
fixed all the glass in here took the
floors back to natural stone those who
remember the the half inch of black wax
that built up over 95 years before
all that's gone
what's also interesting is where if you
look in the first installations plans
where people thought they were going to
install the art it was thought at first
that the italian art would be on the
bridge where in fact later the american
paintings including trumbull's art went
and the italian section would be in the
in what was the great lawn gallery of
the sword out building but you look at a
later plant from 8 28 29 after the 26
planting you see it shifted the italian
paintings moved here the american
material moved over here this was very
interesting to all of us as we as we
worked on the program for this because
the thing to know about a project like
our staff and colleagues of undertaking
with both our planners and our
architects and and then our contractors
is the most important thing is you need
to really figure out what do you need
space for then how much space do you
need and then what adjacencies do you
need to make it function that i have to
say is something we went through about
23 or more different modifications of
our plan just trying to improve it and
prove it over this last 14 years and and
and some of only about 11 of which were
cons were really spent in in the more
constructive mode of working on the
buildings
so uh change was certainly something
that was anticipated in the past and
happened
so early on you can see
it was important to know that this had
been planned originally for for italian
art because at one point they did bring
italian art back in here and so when the
gallery was first put in we had always
thought these were hard architectural
details it turned out they were just
plaster and metal mesh to give it an
italian feeling
and so they weren't so integral to the
architecture after all it was really
sort of early sense of installation and
done at a rather elaborate level so we
spent a lot of time worrying about
whether
we should try to maintain the integrity
of certain aspects of these buildings
and what should be done and then later
you see during 1942 the great society
down a name that collection that
katherine dreyer put together with
marcel duchamp
is brought into america given to the
country again right in the middle of a
major war it's an amazing thing how the
these this happened the way it did and
again modern art is shown here you see
oletski you see joseph stella's great
brooklyn bridge for example the great
leger other paintings you'll see
upstairs on the fourth floor you see
them there so collections have moved
around here at the art gallery
constantly over time
and here you see a picture of duchamp in
dreyer's connecticut home with the large
glass tomb the great painting that's on
the fourth floor
and in a sense this society which
started in 1920 was a predecessor of
what i would call the american
alternative art space movement there
weren't any museums in new york at that
time this was 10 essentially 10 years
before moma opened
so the first shows they did were in a
brownstone in new york city and that
whole collection over 1200 works came to
yale with additional bequests by dreyer
when she died in the early 50s
again just some of the master whoops
excuse me must be the great rich nice
grinder
upstairs you'll see three great laundry
islands on a wall
great man ray ray grahams
glass
brancusi's yellow bird
these are just you know five things out
of that incredible collection
so then you go back again into the the
trumbull gallery and some of you
uh
well some of you know what none of them
here actually would remember in the 30s
i'm sure to say but here this was the
gallery which is now again where you'll
see
american paintings of the first five
decades of the 20th century but for a
while this again was where it trembles
uh paintings in early american fortress
were along with american decorative arts
when there that wasn't that much space
for for such elsewhere
and interestingly enough all the way
back down in what was that wide open uh
uh ancient arts galleries on the first
floor of suerto you can see they built
temporary walls and curtains and that
was used for temporary exhibitions at
many times both in 1950 and 51.
so the gallery's always been on somewhat
of a stress level as to where and how to
site collections and get them in a in a
place and manner that would be more
satisfying in relationship to the actual
architecture and it really hasn't until
this great master plan that president
levin authorized in a campaign that
really tried to address
all
two of these buildings plus the building
that came after which was louis cons
which of course hadn't yet been built in
1951.
some of you who go into the dura europas
gallery now and there are some of you
who studied in this room who studied
when that used to be a two-star affair
we'll remember vincent scully lecturing
in the old yale art gallery and here's
vince up at the
up at the front and he then later
finished his career in this very
auditorium he taught continuously from
1947 to 2008 61 straight years
unbelievable
this was that same space i just showed
you in 1951 it became our trumbull
gallery and when i came to yale helen
cooper and pat kane and others had
installed american decorative arts uh in
in the upper part of the sword out
building
great portraits by copley these are
abigail's
adam's relatives
and then you look back into sword how
this was the long gallery this is
charles montgomery another very famous
professor who taught here and created
the the wonderful installation by
tremief and geismer which juxtaposed
american furniture with paintings and
here's a very young patricia kane who's
i think maybe in the audience tonight
who worked with david barquist who's
also here and now john stuart gordon
figuring out how they were going to
install that just as they've done now in
a new next generation for street hall so
again change has been the constant here
in terms of
what uh what to do with the collections
and god are they spectacular pat's now
at work on a definitive show on great
newport rhode island colonial furniture
this being one of the greatest examples
you'll ever see over in street hall
america it's great a silver collection
potentially unrivaled almost anywhere
certainly an equal with philadelphia the
met in boston is right here at this
university and downstairs
wonderful pieces
i think david barcquist i believe is in
the audience who did the meyer myers
retrospective there's great work by many
others here
and here's that long gallery again you
can see it here and you can see this is
right now if you go upstairs this is
where the solid wall drawing is on the
on the back back wall of the east end
that's changed a bit
here again is looking into the
long gallery at another point in time
this is what we did to it in the year
2000
we we took out the uh
chemical geissner plan and all the rug
that was on the floor took that out and
just said let's see what it looks like
just to bring natural light back in here
put american paintings in it redo the
floors and show a few donors the
potential of what these buildings hold
i'm happy to say within three or four
months we had a couple of very large
donations to take care of street hall
where you've been today people figured
out immediately
what what what what could be done with
what's the beauty of this architecture
and this was just this this was with
modest attention
no no more than you'd bring to just
doing a major exhibition that you'd tour
and again the other thing that happened
here is we started to do some wonderful
looking at our collections as we
planned to move out of the con building
and and renovate it first
we got our conservation lab up much more
actively in this great portrait of
yosemite which you see by bierstadt as
you go off the elevator street hall was
so dark and miscolored you couldn't even
identify at the time the figures on
horse going up the wonderful path
you could see a very distant and sort of
faded out merced river below
and i can't tell you how much more
beautiful this
picture is today i've had the pleasure
of spending every summer for 63 years in
this park so i have a personal love for
this particular painting
those of you on the east coast who love
the mountains love this place mount
katahdin by frederick church so yet
again there's great pictures not just
portraits
great american landscape paintings all
through the collection
wonderful works that document an
american rural life becoming industrial
life and homer's the mill
homer's croquet game
and think about this too when street
hall was built and
opened in 1866
uh the works of people like homer and
others and
that was contemporaneous with the actual
architecture what was happening this has
been true all along the way that the
things that were collected and given to
yale were often either made
contemporaries contemporaneously or
collected and then later given to yale
as the architecture itself grew the
great fortress of john biglin in the
single skull
the schreiber brothers rowing on the
river
the great portraits that came
from edward hopper many of these i've
just shown you were the gifts of stephen
clark whose collection just
improved this museum in a staggering
manner
all of these pictures are on view
upstairs with many many more
this also is someone's favorite painting
is in the audience so i tended to tease
earlier
and so here you are again you'd expect
that well another of course another
expansion would have been underway and
planned and yes indeed there was one you
see here's where the swardle building
ended and in 1941
philip goodwin who had built the
addition of the museum of modern art was
already with the plan he'd worked on it
a number of times
and what happened around that time
world war ii breaks out right so world
war ii breaks out sorry everybody we
can't stop right now and build a an art
gallery uh extension that there's gonna
have to be a weight on that so this
didn't happen
and then after the war
the great louis khan building took place
and it only took place interestingly
enough because aerosarinen got so busy
who was the primary architect working at
yale who would have had the job got so
busy with his big corporate commissions
that this young guy
khan
who was teaching here and and
stimulating the students tremendously
uh took got the got the job and it was
his first major building
and i can tell you this was this is how
it looked this was had what had to be
torn down this is later what rudolph
rudolph's architecture building went
but if you looked at this
this construction site as a university
planner you might have been a little
alarmed right
this was done at time and materials back
then and the mccumber construction
company when i read their files was
fabulously happy to have this commission
because
there was a committee known to the
faculty as the no no louis committee and
they it was the faculty the responsible
members of the faculty at least fiscally
were always trying to say no to his next
request
whereas others including charles sawyer
and and uh and other other people who
wanted to support him always out voted
them three to two when he kept getting
the chance to go forward but it was
built by time and materials no one had
seen a building
like this the tetrahedral ceiling party
had to build a section of and prove it
would even stand up
and it's it was really
quite amazing that all of a sudden this
was erected and opened uh and this is
looking at it from the backside but it
was just a sensation when the building
opened
in 1953 and filled up in 54.
and within it right away we had the
great uh again movement of the art
school in the art gallery collections in
together with the hiring of alvin
eisenmann later on uh
walker evans came to yale it's another
great teacher distinguished artists and
leaders in their own right great
teachers
and then on the entire fourth floor was
the school of architecture so you can
just start to tick off who
who went to school there including james
polshek who's polsheck firm became and
he had our great architects but norman
foster richard rogers robert stern
charles guathmay timberlake it goes on
and on they were all up on that fourth
floor
uh making uh
models and drawings right and left and
and some of the greatest architects in
the world came out of that building
before they moved across the street 10
years later
here's a view of looking back at the con
building in 71
it had started to have some problems and
i'll explain what they were but inside
the building was glorious
louis khan's pogo system was beautiful
it was these five by ten foot panels
that
were spring-loaded in place hence the
word pogo but you might notice one thing
in here that infuriated khan mr rudolph
and others came over
and put black bears at the bottom and
stopped the light from making these
pogos float in air
they also uh
andrew ritchie came from moma with more
of a white wall sensibly covered all the
the masonry block with plywood and then
sheetrock for a while so it a lot of
it's it's it's greatness as architecture
sort of clad
and sheltered a bit for a while
nonetheless incredible collection
started coming into yale the collections
of susan morsillis richard brown baker
in the 60s started to show up some of
which you'll see in the new bennetts and
galleries upstairs
great works by pollock
and this again the the book we just
published by baker is get there get
there first and decide promptly you know
he's buying pollux at 3 500
uh by getting into the gallery first and
saying i think this looks interesting
i'll take that time and time again he
bought wonderful works as did
hillis and and others
all their works came directly from
artists like robert motherwell the great
spanish elegy you see here
the wonderful works of rothko and others
uh came from catherine ordway
interestingly four of el's greatest
donors were women who had nothing to do
with the
university but loved the fact that it
was a teaching museum and i would give
some credit to that to the street hall
notion that women were actively teaching
and studying at yale almost 100 years
before the college became co-ed
wonderful young scholars were here
becoming curators helen cooper bought
this great
champion piece from stuart davis at the
time she purchased it as a young period
it was the most expensive work yale had
ever bought and boy are we glad she was
able to purchase it when she did
great works by de kooning richard
diebenkorn came in from donors like
richard twiggs smith and others who
followed and it's just been a succession
of remarkable things that have come to
the gallery over time
now we're up to the year 2003 just
before we're
we've been asked to now that art history
has decided it would like a new building
next to the rudolph building
how would we develop a plan to to fully
use all three of these buildings in a
sense recoup the galleries
all remaining architecture historical
architecture and and link it together
and the con building because of its
failing mechanical systems and leaks in
the roof we tackled first even though it
was the the least of old of the
buildings
and here you can see the kind of
problems it had the only major design
flaw in the con building really was when
he built it he used straight bar steel
that had no thermal break between the
the weather of the outside inside so we
had freezing weather outside warm inside
the
steel would twist and torque and the
double plane grass glass cracked
incessantly and the place started to
look like a greenhouse
the other thing that happened is the
heatern system which should have really
been two two coils high the rust inside
windows were popping sometimes falling
out
at the same time
25 years later khan finishes completes
the great hill center for british art
and you have two of the greatest museum
buildings in america to cheek the jowl
in tandem with one another now composing
really two masterpieces in modern
american architecture but this building
needed love and attention you can see
its roof had been covered over to create
a ancient art galleries when the others
had been used for other purposes that
needed to be taken out the whole curtain
wall had to be replaced and entirely new
to getting back the old
sculpture courtyard built much in the
way a lot of the moats that you have
around yale college that you know khan
was very cognizant of the context in
which it was working
had to patch in the whole building with
with insulation while we worked inside
it to prevent the floor from buckling
and then finished it up beautifully this
is how it looked if you were looking
down from the rudolph architecture
school that's not a bad building to be
inspired by as you think about being an
architect yourself
and you'll notice that we moved the
richard serra
stacks sculpture over there once we
reinstalled the sculpture garden you'll
see a sense of that before but again
just look at this building reinstalled
empty how beautiful it is space
there are moments in these renovations
where you sometimes come in and say god
the empty space itself is so beautiful
you hardly want to put anything in it at
least for a while here you can see the
the only thing we did that changed the
look of this building is always to put
one more row of uh
heating coils on it and i'm happy to say
all the the conites that you know
watched just like hot hawks didn't even
notice we did that but we we
we
we put a one-inch thermal break between
all the the the new profiled metal and
change it from steel to to aluminum and
it's been functioning beautifully ever
since it was tested i could tell you all
about that how we did it but that was
interesting too
the first thing we did which i think was
so appropriate to the notion of what a
teaching museum might be was to let the
first show be curated by a group of
students
and we had already restored the uh the
building itself the sculpture courtyard
and put wonderful new works by uh martin
furrier starting to again collect
artists who we neglected to collect joel
shapiro you see the great work of david
smith by charlie benson's collection now
out in front of street hall got that all
fixed up and then as of next tuesday
when we cut open the window of the
ribbon yet again at 12 12 12 people came
in
and saw what was what was the
beautifully restored con building and
the first thing they saw was an
exhibition curated by seven yale
students and they're surrounded by pam
franks who i believes here in the
audience who was our curator of academic
affairs at the time now our deputy
director for collections education who
started what's now been six student
curated exhibitions we thought as a
teaching museum there should be more
students being our gallery guides our
teachers they should be given more
opportunities to do shows just the way
we professional adults get to do so we
said you're the first one's on the spot
to do it we want you to react to louis
khan's building any of the sculpture in
the building that was made from 53 on is
yours to choose so right away they dug
into some of the construction photos
look at this fabulous view of the con
stairwell before it was actually
finished in construction
look at how it looks later so
people come from all over the world
simply to stand in this one stairwell
here and then go across the british
archdealers
the center and standing it's and neither
stay all parts of the buildings but both
stairwells are truly magical
students put together a fabulous show
not only works in our collection here
you see a wonderful white rachel white
reed brought from across the street at
the british
center and not only did they
design and create the show they had to
install it they had to give all the
talks they had to do the catalog they
had to do everything and so they learned
exactly what it is we do and they were
front and center is the place open it
was also a wonderful time and we've now
added in the last 14 years four new
collecting departments to the museum
making its collections truly
encyclopedic and global and the addition
of an african art department again fully
endowed and named by james ross and
charles beninson uh entered into the
second floor of khan and here you see
fred lamp
one of the first phd students from yale
who also was in the peace corps in
africa became our first benefits and
curator and it's been here ever since
many people would be president i think
paul walter's here in the audience so
many people have given
artwork to the
museum and here as a matter of fact i
think right behind you are some of the
works that have just come in the great
pottery collection from paul walter the
ones on the table are from charles
bennettson great collection
and again right away
with a lot of our students who are here
we're teaching this is horus ballard
who's now in the phd program down at nyu
teaching with a group school students
and adults
anna hammond one of our colleagues who
came in and helped us really start our
whole publication editorial department
at an important time
and some of the wonderful artworks that
came in not only for mr bennett's
mothers then we moved up into having all
of a sudden much expanded asian art
galleries
named by bruce dayton who also endowed
the position there for
david sensabaugh who became the dayton
curator we also hired santiko oki a
great specialist in japanese ceramics
and painting and those collections
started to grow with wonderful gifts
and david is one of the most gifted
teachers you could ever hope to have in
a museum and that collection frankly is
rotated more frequently than any of our
collections in the whole museum
the european art collection again was
rotated more and more we
hired larry
cantor part time to come from the lehman
collection and think about spending some
time with us helping us better
understand the works we had
we also added
new installations to that department
again full of great pictures manet young
john marciari came our way became a
great younger curator helped us discover
the velasquez that's been lounging in
our basement for 90 years that's been
conserved now
major
uh
major attributions from titian to
frangelico to velasquez to
van dijk and others have been made with
having people who finally have a greater
knowledge of that early european art
that's been at yale and of course we
were able to show more but not that much
of our modern contemporary collections
you'll notice those who have been coming
here you seldom get to see maybe more
than one rothko or one pollock or or
never a whole group of these things
together we just didn't have enough
space and some of the large scale art
was never really big enough or the
juxtapositions as nice as they were in
some way
didn't make the same lyrical poetic
space that kind of sensed with each
other that i think you're you're seeing
now as you look through the collections
and of course the great paintings by van
gogh
and you know given by stephen clark
great things by lichtenstein by richard
brown baker were all sort of
cheeked to jowl with each other at the
same time we hired jennifer gross and
with me coming here we had started a
much more active endowed program for
visiting artists with them spending time
amongst us and also with the school of
art and so janine and tony was one doh
hosuh a yo graduate another started
acquiring works by these artists some of
which you see in kathleen chaffee's uh
wonderful once removed
exhibition this is her first show on
khan west right now on the shin
galleries
and we were able to lure suzanne borish
away from the met as our wonderful lead
curator for prince drawings and
photography again
i haven't hired anyone who wasn't
interested in teaching students and
spending time with them which i think is
a hallmark of any
teacher and professor and certainly been
true of us who work in the museum we
like young people and we want them to
come at us
this wonderful new duffy study center
now has two major spaces where you can
come in and select from over 50 000
works that are housed right on the
fourth floor
and again young people here elizabeth
derose got her first major show with a
show of uh riki shigoya kiki smith tip
dunham
jane hammond and
the other half of the gallery was jasper
johns not bad for someone just applying
to graduate school she did a knockout
job
but on this same floor you have
wonderful works by wins the homer don't
miss by the way right now when you go
into the painting sculpture galleries in
in street hall there's a little
wonderful nook as you come off that
first gallery and five of homer
watercolors including this is around
view right now
we started collecting african-american
art in a very big way over 400 pieces
have been collected in the last 12 years
very significant ones this is a great
collage by bearden one of his most
important early works
wonderful images by photography the
photography program has grown
with a tremendous amount of new work
again i've been privileged to be an
adjunct professor in the school of art
and to work closely with chip benson and
todd papa george who were here tonight
so
you might imagine
having done the first great show i saw
yale todd did a show of walker evans and
and robert frank not juxtaposing these
particular images but
evans had taught here we we started to
really collect photography in a big way
and that's continued as you well know
but also up there were great drawings
this pollock drawing that's on view
upstairs is one i think one of his
greatest drawings ever it was the poster
from omaha's retrospective show and
it's seldom been on public view here
it's up there right now on the
bennington galleries
and of course soloid entered into our
into our life and we now have four lewis
on view in the collection we did his
retrospective at mass moca with williams
college that's there for 25 years and 50
of his wall drawings and his archives
are here coming here yale as a gift and
he'll be seeing more of that with
students trained to do them one of the
things we did when we opened the con
villain is we spent a lot of time before
outfitting it talking to the students
about what kind of use should happen to
the lobby many of you may remember
before when the building had a tiny
elevator you couldn't even take a
painting more than seven feet up the
elevator up the stairs so this space had
been often used for exhibition space the
students that make it like a big
friendly living room no one pays any
admission or buys a ticket when they
come here make it a place where we can
meet and talk and get open on a thursday
night and they told us a lot of stuff
that made utter sense so we with joel
sanders who
worked at the architecture school
we asked him to do some designs for us
and
this was the first version of our
visitor service desk you can see we've
stripped it down and made it much
tucked it in on another side of the
building to open the space more as it's
it's become used more and more by people
needing to gather but when we first
opened the gallery i've reinstalled some
of the same paintings christian bakers
one of our recent yale grads but
immediately people came in and started
to treat this as space where they could
meet each other whether it was a class
or friends and then go off into the
museum not having to be
forced to have a buying experience we we
did away with a traditional museum store
and said we'd focus the resources that
we put into that into our education
program
instead and you can buy our own
publications there but
we've really taken most other things out
and another thing we noticed that we've
really encouraged is we liked it when
people started to date in the yale art
gallery and they're what we've we've let
the students know there were just 350 of
them in here dating the other night the
175 students who work the british arts
center and the gallery got to bring
their boyfriends or girlfriends in here
but this started to happen a lot more
excuse me whip someone backwards here
uh
this started to happen noticeably after
we we listened to the students and also
started the gallery guide program with
gallery guides from each of the
residential colleges the students show
up for each other's tours the same they
would for a play or a sporting event and
that's transformed the use of the
gallery and made it much more a part of
the
college
all during this we started also a major
art drive to enhance the collection
almost 20 000 works came in
in the first 10 years of that and it was
done very quietly and the first donor to
kick it off was paul mellon and it's not
a bad way to start with
the greatest watercolor it was still in
private hands which was the you sell the
john bigland aikens painting this was
the watercolor that matched it he sent
it up to
yale in honor of jules brown and said i
hope this will sort of get your little
campaign underway
it was amazing and many other works came
later by gift and bequest you'll see a
lot of those upstairs
just fabulously generous man and
and
really it was a great fortune to have
met him the last day he came to yale and
to spend it in the gallery
also with the gift of the beninson
collection major pieces that people
would drive anywhere to come see came
our way this great merits built by kurt
schwitters was the
the thing that when shown at moma the
first
twitter show way back one you can see
had a huge influence on robert
rauschenberg and jasper johns
right up until the week charlie
bennettson died moma was begging him for
this picture please send everything to
hill but not this
and charlie was strong he held out to
the end and
all these other great pictures of his
came to and it's it's a this alone is
worth driving to new haven to see if in
terms of modern art
also the great shaffer collection from
europe which had been loaned to yale and
monica schaefer is here with us from
malaga tonight uh gifts from that
collection great core bae this fabulous
george gross painting drink and drowzen
which so much brings up some of the
issues today of the inequality between
people of wealthy and people who are
really in tough shape out on the street
uh great works from that collection are
on view here and again some wonderful uh
planned bequests
in store for this teaching museum from
uh fro dr schaefer and her husband who
lived to the great age of 100 wonderful
man
along with uh other things from charles
benson some of the greatest stuart
davises you could ever hope to have and
we were able to buy the last great
charles murphy painting of the artist
who went to yale and was cole porter's
great friend here and went to paris
wonderful pictures le bibliotech if this
isn't a picture about looking carefully
and studying and reading and thinking
about architecture the world and in this
case both sculpture and that that's
portrait of ralph waldo emerson thinking
about philosophy you know
it's a wonderful picture to have at a
teaching museum things like this just
came pouring in
i told you about earlier about these the
sarah there were commissions at the time
amy gates was very brave to commission
this work by richard sarah it almost got
her fired it was called stacks it was
put in the old library of the art
history department and they hated it and
went after her with tooth and tongue but
then finally
backed off solo it's first wall drawing
was not brought here by me but by sasha
newman who
commissioned it for the wall at the
other end of the the building some of
you may remember it
uh but later when we took the roof off
the
con courtyard and
repurposed it richard came up and i
suggested it move here and boy he
he he totally grieved the chance to work
with khan posthumously was quite special
the piece looks great up there
you can go up and look at it any time
on a clear day or rainy day and it just
it holds that space beautifully
again during the renovations con
building was done we started to think
about what we were going to do in the
sward owl building and tried a number of
different uh
installations there this is susan
matheson putting a number of things on
view for the the classics department and
those needed to teach with roman art and
again this you can see here the floor
that's been restored that's pure stone
it had this wax that had become almost
black so again the discontinuity have
just surfaced of all and was quite
pronounced but we didn't realize what a
huge change that was going to be until
we stripped the floors later but the
idea of testing out whether we could put
our collection back in this space was
something that we we found very soon
worked very well
and of course at the same time we
started more and more to invite other
not just our own curators here you see
susan teaching uh one of the directed
studies classes that jane levin brings
over when they when they read homer they
come over and look at great faces when
they're they we're working there's david
sensible again with another class here's
ed cayman one of our great faculty
members teaching japanese art started to
integrate the faculty much more into the
life of the museum and again
pam franks this was i think pam i think
this was probably your
maybe a fifth or sixth show this is a
show called embodied black identities in
american art which for the first time
brought three yale students together
with three students from the university
of maryland in a show we did together
and we started a whole program of
loaning works from our collection to
other college and university art museums
and just received a very handsome
endowment to continue that
whoops excuse me these students again
were very much a part of our teaching
program and the gallery guide program
got stronger and stronger here you see
them working with the school classes
that come in these are some of our first
gallery guides who returned after for a
10-year reunion
and now we get back to what what we
needed to do with the rest of these
buildings but we'd sort of already taken
care of khan and here we thought we
really needed to just get as much of
that normal office space and everything
else out of here make much of this
building dedicated to displaying of art
and to also figure out some way if we
could with our architects to get more
temporary exhibition space up into the
building than all the way across
the
top floor of khan if possible this you
can see already changes a little bit
from what you see upstairs this is the
print
study area now and and didn't become a
gallery this is a much bigger gallery
here
but one of the key features to see if we
could somehow
take put a gallery on top a structure on
top of this building to gain more actual
exhibition space and this is where our
great architects idiot and our educator
engineers were able to help us
if you look uh in the in the buildings
they come across here this tower
actually in suarta was hollow up above
the second floor there had been a little
mezzanine kind of
american arts office which before had
been a
a
conservation studio but we were
wondering what might be done to the top
of that here you have the khan building
and then the british art center which
had very different lighting system on
top you couldn't build anything on top
of it but lo and behold
we thought well maybe if we find a way
to put steel down through the structural
bearing wall of the building we could
get a whole
new gallery back there that wouldn't be
seen from anywhere really other than
almost the fourth floor of the founders
room of the british arts center
and and not really anywhere else and so
if you look here this was the glass
roof and ceiling that went over the top
the building before by pulling this back
in here you're really not adding that
much more of a visual
problem in terms of perception you don't
see any of it from the floor
from the streets so we decided to go
with that there was a lot of review and
potential consternation as to whether
that was the right thing to do but
essentially what you see is we dropped
in a whole new set of galleries here
lined the floors up here built up two
more floors in the tower and then had to
deal with the problem of how do you get
people because all these buildings have
to be readily accessible how do you get
people through the disjunctions of floor
plates that don't actually align between
street hall and the swardal building
bridge that connect as you go across
high street those were the challenges
that our architects at enad took on with
great delight so they could do some of
their own new architecture amidst these
these three great buildings and this was
their potential notion of how that
fourth floor gallery could look with the
some of the society dana neem collection
in it here's just one photograph of how
it looks actually right now you can go
up after this and see some of it
yourself
we also in adding the tower to the
building thought that we could get
another whole floor that would line up
with that and another gallery next to it
and that we would we could get a second
floor on even further up this has become
the new jane and richard levin study
gallery where faculty members can put
works out for uh display
and um
and so that's uh on view there and
there's we put a wonderful uh
a wonderful
photography gallery in there right now
which has been outfitted by joshua chong
and mrsa
nakasoni and for the first time we're
going to see a much more ongoing display
of photography always on view here as
well as some major temporary exhibitions
of photography that continue the
tradition of the great robert adams
retrospective that many of you saw here
recently
this is this is a photograph of the
brooklyn bridge by my great pal richard
benson who's out there in the audience
wonderful portrait of shea stadium
looks like a good mets game underway
with a
plane coming into laguardia todd's been
the chairman of that department for many
years wonderful platinum print of
of the hoover dam by lois connor who
headed up the undergraduate teaching
program there and the the collection is
full you know lois didn't mind seeing
her work next to this great image of
hoover dam robert frank along with the
grand canyon and one of the first
a-bomb sites
and other great pictures by the likes of
frank and
evans
friedlander and many many other more
contemporary artists so again did
fantastic improvement in that collection
that continues to grow i think some of
you already been up to the rooftop where
again what we found we could pull this
structure back
from the sword out
and put in new stone and you still show
here when you go up there you'll see
that the glass and steel roof used to go
right like this up here and then peek
down the other side all of these were
just open spaces and open to the sky
there was there was nothing there before
it was just sort of almost like a folly
above the two floors but the thought was
that we could create some kind of
wonderful outdoor sculpture uh courtyard
and indeed uh we were able to do that
and this is before we put any benches or
anything else out a lot of the
installation photos i have now since we
just finished the installation about
five days ago six days ago are not all
that fresh but and they're a couple that
still have stuff in the way but let me
show you a few of the final pieces so
here you again you look at this was the
problem we had to figure out how do you
how do you get into from the bridge over
street hall which is two floors now how
do you get
down here into the into the floors of
american painting sculpture deck arts
and then into this wonderful new nolan
center for art and learning which has
been endowed with
not just spaces for students to live and
work but
endowed with positions which are now
called curators of academic affairs
there's seasoned museum pros who are
long experienced with phds and great
teaching experience and their job is to
look at the whole yale curriculum and
fan out to professors and say hey we
have stuff that we think
you can use in your courses and we'd
love to have you over to see if it would
make some sense to have a section a
class session or two or maybe even teach
a whole class here and there are now
eight object classrooms where you can do
that i know dolores hayden is in the
audience and has used our collections in
photography extensively as a matter of
fact the robert adams show we had seven
academic departments using the uh the
implications of bob's work so that we
find that is working and we're gonna
continue that strongly
um so this was the the notion of some
sense of what an elevator might look
like we decided it needed to be
translucent
and
and only clear just on the ends to let
you know where you're coming and going
from and i think you'll like that that
over the sort of total fishbowl style
that others have taken
and that allows you to come in off the
floor plates and get down to these
places for both for handicapped access
and access for our big art carts
and this again is you know the notion of
a little odd color in terms of how it
photographed but it's a beautiful space
now and we just had to sacrifice one
little mini gallery as you came into
street hall and when you step off of
that
uh on to this you're back in the river
street hall what it used to look like no
one has seen an exhibition in this space
no one alive has this is now looking the
way it did back in 1866.
so now when this is reopened you've got
the lrt area with the the gallery here i
want to bring it back to that the bac
here
you've got this
the holcomb green school here we have
space potentially remo reserved for a
drama school expansion and there's
another site i'm not supposed to talk
about that's nearby that's the
alternative
under richard benson's leadership we got
the all of this built with the debra
burke's building the new sculpture
building done and that was shared first
with the architects when they they
needed a space to go before they their
building was built we had to plan this
as a whole team so everyone moved around
and sacrificed certain things they might
have wanted to do in space and time in
order to get it all done together the
arts
library spanned a double and this
building ended up being cheek to jowl
this is the new art history building so
rick levin really asked all of us to
work as a team together and we i have to
say we're very happily were able to do
that and same time the british art
center did its year of the roof and
improved its building and it's going to
do some further conservation work that
maybe amy and her colleagues are up to
so
going forward
this is how it looks today
and we finished it in april someone went
up on the roof over cesar pelle's office
i think it's quite wonderful you have
one of our former dean still planting
most of the great buildings he does all
over the world right here on chapel
street people are finally starting to
realize a lot happens on chapel street
it's quite amazing what goes on here but
all three of these buildings not only
were finished in the inside in the way
you see but all of their
skylights their slates their the roof
was re all the stonework was repointed
or replaced or cleaned and they're
really in tip-top shape now and and
ready for probably a good 40 to 50 years
of of enduring service before they need
to be worked on again so here's an
interesting statistic for you
1866
1928 1953 the total number of deferred
maintenance years that were corrected by
these three
renovations is 280 years
so all of you in this room and there are
many of you have been helpers in making
this happen
what's happened this last 14 15 years is
really a wonderful thing we've helped
preserve a legacy and a stewardship of
art at yale it's really unrivaled at any
other university and frankly few cities
in the world when you add in the british
arts center and remarkably it's it's
free you don't no one has to pay
anything to come into these museums they
can come in as frequently as they want
for a short time or a long time and it's
a great report resource not just to yale
but to the new haven community and
anyone who wants to come our way
we've tried to put out some sculpture
right away you might notice that yale
isn't so great on signage
you know you wouldn't have necessarily
really known you were coming into a
museum district in the old days and so
one of the first things we wanted to put
up and decided some more anderson better
signage was
not particularly appropriate with
the british arts center having a mini
retrospective auntie carol we've put up
one of his great works from charlie
bennettson's collection and david
rebecca d today his first
colored steel sculpture so they're the
two pals side by side representing our
partnership with our colleagues across
the street
and there's more work behind but this is
how this this if you were over in amy's
office and took a photograph on a on a
nice clear day this is what she looks at
now
and it's it's beautifully uh beautifully
fixed up
and the other thing worth saying is
there were wonderful things that
happened along the way all of samuel
yellen's gates were
were cleaned and fixed and conserved
where need be and opened up wonderful
art blacksmith from
massachusetts john race came in and
directed working with pat kane and
others researched samuel yellen's
original designs all of this had been
they'd run out of money this was there
was nothing but sort of some curly q
wire had been put in between these and
the the code people said they made us
cover them up with
fiberglass netting for a while and then
later
said that's not going to do come up with
something else or you can't open the
building well this wonderful blacksmith
did three floors of these beautiful
designs with alternating dogwood
blossoms and it was his first major
commission we just opened the new donor
wall
done by nick benson the first dual
macarthur winner a fellow winner from a
single family
again congratulations chip the jeans
seem all right over there
and
he he came to work here and there are
other artists now uh working in the
building so
some wonderful things have happened that
also allowed us to
bring living artists more fully into
this renovation so here again now is the
beautiful
ancient galleries you can see the floors
are all
all that awful waxes here the whole room
has continuity again that never had for
many many years
beautiful light
beautiful collection that's grown
tremendously under susan matheson's
leadership and and lisa brody has worked
with her to open our
europa's collection one of the things
that thrilled a lot of us was about the
first week it opened all of a sudden the
art students weren't drawing
and they've been there ever since
they keep coming back so you know we've
seen a real
bringing together of both art historians
and the art school the use of the
building as well as the university at
large and that makes us happy great
conservation projects went underway this
huge uh renovation of the jurassic
murals uh
this was done this is satin crates for
almost not since the 1920s carol snow
and a team of our museum technicians
did this huge 23-foot piece that this
song at the opening to entrance to the
big byzantium show at the met and then
came here for our opening whole new
technique of how to do this work great
searing release went back on view these
are two of just a five
there's multiple examples of stuff
that's not up so you'll see changes over
time
then the wonderful uh
whole new collection from the library
came the whole coins metals collection
which was been augmented under
william metcalf's leadership with
probably four or five or six new
collections that have come since it's
the second largest greek
and roman coin collection in america now
and it was named in honor of villa lyon
pratt who was one of the first graduates
of the yale school of art who studied
with
weir
when weird
taught him everything he could he sent
him to he said you got to go to see this
guy saint gardens he's the only other
guy i really can do sculpture in america
i've touched everything i know so saint
gardens designs the 20 and 10 gold piece
uh he does the five and two and a half
and does heals tears bicentennial medal
and many and the great nathan hale
sculpture you know you know on campus
has a wonderful career he and samuel fb
morris were two of the youngest artists
to come out of yale way back when and
this
wonderful gallery of coins and metals is
now augmented with a wonderful classroom
where the art historians used to grill
their phd students for their orals it's
now a classroom where you can call in
everything from pre-columbian to roman
glass to greek sculpture or vases or
coins and metals and a collection of
over a hundred thousand works reside
right next door in the office the idea
is to make this collection readily
accessible we ought to be able to get it
out
love it almost as quickly as you pull a
rare book in the library for examination
jane miller one of our wonderful admin
assistants
uh pulling this out so if you want to
look at a great gold coin fine or maybe
your student wants to come in and look
at this whole collection of wild
porcelain tokens from the uh from china
that we know little about
and maybe you're the one who's going to
do the research on this and figure out
something about a collection that's been
here for
years and years and years and no one has
really studied the opportunities for
research and new scholarship abound in
these collections and that's again part
of what we like to suggest to students
and faculty
this is lisa brody looking into with a
group of students the wonderful miss
raymond from
europas was another project conserved on
the campus she oversaw the whole
installation of that collection
wonderful young scholar teacher
so there's a whole younger generation
being rendered here who are doing
wonderful work
but don't think this is the first time
we've had teaching in the gallery this
is back in the 1930s this is alison alex
chase this woman started teaching again
if you look around here the paintings
from duryaropus on the wall
asian art greek art there's all kinds of
stuff in this room young people not just
from yale college here these are kid new
haven school kids learning about art
from looking at it actively just the way
we do today so to tell you the truth
there's not a lot of brand new ideas and
anything we've done we've just tried to
go back into the history of this place
take some of the best ideas fortify them
fix the buildings and maybe go deeper
and broader and just keep reaching for a
kind of excellence that's been here for
a long long time
and in some cases provide teaching
galleries for departments where we don't
have a full
uh and fully endowed department and
likely can't have one really in the case
of ancient art we have the fabulous
mary miller who was dean of yale college
used to be a head of art history there's
a great
ancient american art collection now
upstairs
and she teaches from it constantly as do
others but emblematic again of what what
happens at yale is
heather hurst one of her great students
went down to chiapas and crawled down
into the underground found the
uh tombs of the bonapark murals
copy them
fastidiously and then went and over some
of you may remember z's tattoo parlor on
chapel street spent three years doing
these murals to full half scale and
we'll be switching out one of the three
tombs each year heather went on to win a
macarthur award at age 28. i mean this
place just keeps turning out remarkable
young artists or young scholars of all
kind and often
their experiences can be traced back to
their engagement in the great library
and museum collections our most recent
collection to be added and one that
makes yale's collection more truly
global in the fact that we'd added the
african and trump other tribal arts of
of that whole area and and
into the
department you saw the floor below we
were able from one single donor tom
jaffe class of 71 had collected the
greatest private collection of of
indo-pacific art everywhere from
taiwan all the way down through the
philippines
and and you know all the way going you
know toward indonesia micronesia all the
way
toward india
and following basically the sea routes
and this is a phenomenal collection
and not only did he
give his and promise all his sculpture
you might see all around the galleries
when you go into wonderful textiles the
greatest textile collection of this kind
in the world was
assembled by anita spurtus and
and her husband jeff jeff holmgren half
of it was sold to the national gallery
of australia and the other half was
going to go to the met until tom stepped
in said i've got to buy it for yale
because i've got the stuff the men made
the women made all the textiles and if
we're going to have a department you've
got to have the best of that
and then he endowed the whole
curatorship we were able to lift ruth
barnes out of the ashmolean oxford to
come be our curator
and most touching of all he named the
gallery in honor of his two teachers at
yale
george kubler and robert ferris thompson
and and
so this honoring of great teaching and
the impact it has on students is
particularly emblematic in this this
wonderful
gift that
has made a whole new department
possible
wonderful wonderful things up there and
and ruth's done a stunning first
installation
now when you go over to street halls
some of you've done and some of you are
going to be able to do here just minutes
is uh the trumbull uh paintings have
been now installed in beautiful new
space a lot more of it now
other galleries uh on the other side
full of great homers and aikens and
other works these wonderful lunettes
that came out of the huntington mansion
that were conserved that sat rolled in
boxes for 90 odd years
this is what again what the galleries
look back like back in the 18
uh
so
you can see they've they've
and this this by the way is downstairs
this this was one of the studios
where the students worked where they
sometimes hung paintings above and that
same
studio now has become one of the great
american decorative arts collections
that pat kaine and john stuart gordon
have just installed
sadako oki and david sensab just
overseen a major
reinstallation of japanese and and asian
art and it leads right through this door
into what's a fabulous series of i think
it's 15 galleries of art that go from
tragento italian to the great uh
the great pictures of van gogh and
cezanne at the end of the bridge
and you see wonderful views where you
look out down the bridge down high
street
students can come in
wonderful views where you come into a
gallery look out onto chapel street we
made a real point with the architects of
wanting you to think not only of what
you were seeing inside but we want you
to be able to look outside often and
have some
relief we think of the museum now really
like a great three-course meal you know
khan's your first chorus sword out your
second maybe the street hauls your third
a great dessert and maybe what you see
on top's the night cap or something
but it's it's rather spectacular and you
now go through these just beautiful
runs of modern art and for the first
time we have great spacious galleries
for our contemporary modern contemporary
collections
again wonderful positioning of some of
the work with the original features of
the architecture
all of a sudden we can start to put many
more of these things together and in all
cases you know there are two more
rothkos in reserve another
three round another great one i mean
every one of these artists we have more
work by
goes on and on john stuart gordon has
been working with pat kane has brought
the collection of modern and
contemporary decorative arts up to now
with the beautiful installation
and the nolan center across the street
hall and down on the first floor has a
whole curatorial library that can be
open to students during the day and in
the evenings and objects classrooms
where they can plan and work on the
exhibitions they're doing
and a student can come in and just study
a single object for pleasure for a
course
her whole classes can come in and be
taught by the likes of kate ezra or
suzanne
borsch pam franks and others here they
are in the duffy print room or down in
one of our curatorial rooms or they can
be working in our conservation labs
they'll hear the work going on in the
huntington
mural lunettes by muy bray so bringing
these young people in direct contact
with original works of art every single
day this museum is open seven days a
week six to the public seven
in total counting the yield community is
what we do
there's music being played in the
gallery more often you may have heard a
lot of it last night from our school of
music
constant talks by faculty here's the
great alex nemeroff who we sadly miss
he's gone back to stanford but
and we've also got wonderful works by
solowitz starting to erupt in the
gallery this leads down the vincent
scala gallery to where you are today
you just walked down here past this
other solid wood wall drawing done by
four students one starts with a three
foot line connects it to the next to the
next and then they go on
an infant item as a force them until
they feel the overall effect it's
satisfying
interesting work here by an elusive
artist named eli benoffles that deals
with the 1863 stamp by
andrew it was done of andrew jackson
during the civil war just a year before
the school of art was found and then
opened so it puts the idea of mark
making every one of these stamps was
hand cancelled in a different manner if
you look at it carefully and digitally
and large so this lost found album of
these stamps that have been magnified
for your attention bring a whole new
sense of how mark making can be thought
of across time of when the art school
started to what the kind of things that
are happening there now
so
we invite you tonight as it's starting
to get darker outside maybe you want to
go up on the roof
this is what amy sees as it gets dark
maybe you want to go up there and hang
out
and maybe you'll feel as levitated as we
do at the end of all this thank you very
much
thank you
okay
now listen
look